nous avons envoyé un caméraman ce fait
doit se promener à stockholm en ces
temps de pandémie
le constat est pour le moins étonnant
les petits suédois sont probablement les
seuls enfants du continent qui vont
encore à l'école
trois mineurs ou des
qu'il sort
pour l'instant ça va car il supporte lui
le virus que nous dit ce père de famille
dont la fille fréquente encore la
garderie mais ne sont-ils pas des
vecteurs
et qu'en est il de la transmission
communautaire alors que les restaurants
les cafés les magasins sont ouverts
je me fie à nos experts et aux décisions
de notre gouvernement qui encourage la
distanciation sociale cette heure la
suède jusqu'à maintenant renoncer au
confinement
il se rabat sur l'eau tout
responsabilisation des citoyens pour
traverser la crise c'est dans notre
culture et nos traditions dit le dr anne
darwin stone un des architectes de cette
approche qui se veut l'exception
ça veut dire entre autres laissez le
virus se propage et met lentement pour
ne pas engorger les hôpitaux une
approche dite expérimentale qui est
contesté par les plus grands cerveaux
scientifique du pays les autorités sans
tête dit la docteure cécilia soderbergh
naucler une des centaines de chercheurs
qui dans une lettre ouverte à plaider
pour des mesures plus sévères
déjà le tiers des foyers pour personnes
âgées à stockholm rapportent des
éclosions maman
cette jeune femme est une de celles qui
doutent de plus en plus du grand paris
de la suède dans la capitale la
situation est déjà alarmante aux soins
intensifs du plus grand hôpital la suède
enregistre plus de 400 morts c'est plus
que tous les 10 est content et en
finlande en norvège et au danemark
combiner le gouvernement suédois reconnu
dans le monde entier comme étant avant
gardiste pourrait à son tour se résigner
à emboîter le pas dès cette semaine
le parlement étudie une demande du
gouvernement qui veut désormais les
pouvoirs nécessaires pour imposer de
nouvelles restrictions is it amaral
thérèse coup radio canada montréal